you're telling me that you've done 300
videos and they still only get 20 or 30
views a couple things you've made enough
content with not enough views where my
normal talk of like you're being
impatient goes out the window yeah it's
really tough to give this advice because
it almost comes across as hurting one's
feelings but on the flip I'm actually
excited about it you are very rare
you've gone hard enough long enough
around a certain way that you've given
me the opportunity to give rare advice
which is hey you can't do that no
more you have to completely switch it up
that has been proven to me with those
numbers as it does not work don't dwell
that that's happening but you definitely
need to mix something up with your
content you got to try different
that doesn't need to be devastating like
oh if nobody likes me or I suck that
needs to be how do I make different
content